>> Jeanine: THE WHITE HOUSE
TRYING TO SMOOTH THINGS OVER
AFTER JOHN FETTERMAN'S DEBATE
DISASTER.
THE MEDIA FORCED TO ADMIT THAT
FETTERMAN'S ROCKY PERFORMANCE
HAS RAISED ANXIETY AMONG
DEMOCRATS, SOME OF WHOM ARE ON
EDGE THAT IT COULD SWAY
UNDECIDED VOTERS WITH 12 DAYS TO
GO.
THE CANDIDATE HIMSELF SAYS DON'T
WORRY.
>> TO BE HONEST, DOING THAT
DEBATE WASN'T EASY.
AFTER THAT STROKE I GOT KNOCKED
DOWN, BUT I GOT BACK UP.
I'M GOING TO FIGHT FOR EVERYONE
IN PENNSYLVANIA WHO EVER GOT
KNOCKED DOWN THAT THEY EVER HAD
TO GET BACK UP.
>> Jeanine: AND THE WHITE HOUSE
AND THE MEDIA SAYS YOU GOT IT
ALL WRONG.
HE'S ACTUALLY IMPRESSIVE.
>> IN PERSONAL CONVERSATIONS
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS HAD WITH
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, THE
PRESIDENT HAS FOUND HIM TO BE
IMPRESSIVE, INCREDIBLY BRIGHT
AND TALENTED PERSON THAT IS JUST
AS CAPABLE AS ALWAYS TO CARRY
OUT HIS OFFICE.
>> FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT AND
WINSTON CHURCHILL SERVED AT THE
HIGHEST OFFERSES BEFORE
TELEVISION COULD COVER THEIR
MOVE AND HAVING TWITTER PUMPING
OUT INSTANT REACTIONS.
THE PAINFUL REVIEWS WERE ODDLY
DISCONNECTED TO THIS COUNTRY'S
OWN EXPERIENCE WITH ILLNESS IN
ELECTED OFFICE.
>> BEHIND THE SCENES, A HOT MIC
CAPTURED HOW DEMOCRATS REALLY
FEEL ABOUT FETTERMAN.
>> Jeanine: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
NOTICED, GREG, BUT THE PRESIDENT
AS SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER IS
SAYING, REALLY DIDN'T HURT US
THAT MUCH.
THE PRESIDENT IS CROSSING HIS
FINGERS LIKE LET'S HOPE SO.
THEY KNOW IT WAS A DISASTER.
>> Greg: YEAH, I WOULD GIVE MY
PINKY TOE TO HEAR A CONVERSATION
WITH FETTERMAN AND JOE BIDEN.
>> Jeanine: LOOK AT THE FINGERS
GO UP.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHERE HE IS.
JOE JUST LIKES TALKING TO HIM
BAKES IT MAKES HIM FEEL SMART.
FETTERMAN IS NOT JUST A SENATE
CANDIDATE, HE'S A HERO.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE TELLS US HE'S
A HERO.
I SUSGUEST THEY ERECT A STATUE
OF HIM.
IN TEN YEARS WHEN PROTESTERS
REMEMBER THAT HE'S AN OLD WHITE
GUY THAT CHASED A BLACK GUY WITH
A GUN, THEY'LL HAVE TO TEAR IT
DOWN.
IT'S AMAZING HOW THE STORIES
CHANGE OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
IMAGINE IF THE REPUBLICANS RAN A
STROKE VICTIM, HOW WOULD THAT
FLY?
DO YOU REMEMBER THE HEAPS OF
RIDICULES CAME WHEN THEY RAN A
TV HOST?
DEMS WITH NEVER CRITICIZE ANYONE
AGAIN FOR BEING UNFIT FOR
OFFICE.
IT'S OBVIOUS HE'S UNFIT FOR
BY PUSHING IT FORWARD, THEY
WILL -- OCTOBER, THEY'LL HAVE
THAT ARGUMENT AGAIN, BUT NO ONE
SHOULD TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
>> Jeanine: JESSE, A CNN MEDICAL
ANALYST HIT FETTERMAN FOR NOT
DISCLOSING THE SEVERITY OF THE
STROKE.
WE HAVE THAT SOUND.
>> THE CAMPAIGN WAS OPAQUE.
THEY DIDN'T REALLY DISCLOSE THE
DEGREE OF HIS ILLNESS.
DIDN'T KNOW HOW SICK HE WAS.
THERE'S NO SIN IN HAVING A
STROKE.
THERE'S A LOT OF HONOR IN THE
DOGGED DETERMINATION THAT IT
TAKES TO RECOVER.
I ADMIRE THAT.
BUT I DON'T ADMIRE IS THE WAY
THE CAMPAIGN HAS HANDLED THE
DISCLOSURE OF HIS ILLNESS.
>> Jeanine: WITHOUT THE MEDICAL
RECORDS, JESSE, THERE'S NO WAY
TO KNOW WHETHER OR NOT FETTERMAN
HAS HAD A SUBSEQUENT STROKE.
THE HIDING OF THE MEDICAL
RECORDS DON'T TELL US HOW SEVERE
THE STROKE WAS.
SO THERE'S GOT TO BE SOME REASON
FOR THEM TO HIDE IT.
HE SAYS HEY, I HAD A STROKE.
WHAT IS TO HIDE THEN?
>> Jesse: IT'S PROBABLY WORSE
THAN THEY'RE LETTING ON.
THE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
DISRESPECTED IN THE STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA AND IT CONTINUES.
EVERYONE HAS SEEN THIS, JUDGE.
THIS HAS BROKEN THROUGH THE
REGULAR POLITICAL LANDSCAPE.
IF YOU'RE IN PENNSYLVANIA, YOU
PROBABLY HAVE SEEN IT, YOU HEARD
ABOUT IT.
IF YOU'RE A REGULAR PERSON, ALL
YOU THINK OF IS THIS GUY CAN'T
LISTEN AND SPEAK WITHOUT THE
HELP OF A MACHINE.
SO THE MEDIA THINKS THEY'RE
HELPING HIM BY RUNNING THESE
HEADLINES THAT SAY FETTERMAN
DISABILITY IN THE HEADLINE.
IF YOU'RE A CASUAL READER AND
YOU GLANCE, FETTERMAN
DISABILITY.
YOU MADE A GREAT POINT.
IT'S NOT -- HE'S NOT ON
CRUTCHES.
HE'S NOT LOSING AN EYE.
THIS IS A COGNITIVE DISABILITY.
HE CANNOT PROCESS LANGUAGE.
HE CANNOT SPEAK THE LANGUAGE
EFFECTIVELY.
SO YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT SENDING A
GUY THAT IS 100% TO WASHINGTON
TO REPRESENT YOU.
YOU HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
IF THE WHITE HOUSE DOESN'T AT
LEAST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS GUY
ISN'T 100%, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE
TAKING US ALL FOR FOOLS.
YOU CAN STILL SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT
THE?
HE SUFFERED.
HE'S IN THE RECOVERY PHASE.
WE THINK HE'S A FIGHTER AND HE'S
STILL GOT WHAT IT TAKES.
TO SAY THIS GUY IS GREAT IS THE
SAME ADDS HE WAS EVER WAS --
>> Greg: YOU'RE ABLIST IF YOU'RE
CONCERNED.
>> Jesse: HE'S BETTER THAN
BEFORE THE STROKE.
YOU'RE LYING TO US.
AT THIS POINT, IF YOUR A HYPER
PARTISAN DEMOCRAT IN
PENNSYLVANIA, YOU'LL VOTE FOR
FETTERMAN.
IF YOU'RE A MODERATE DEMOCRAT,
IF YOU'RE A SWING VOTER, THERE'S
NO WAY YOU'RE VOTING FOR JOHN
FETTERMAN WITH A CLEAR
CONSCIOUS.
>> Jeanine: THE PROBLEM IS
650,000 PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY
VOTED, DANA.
THE TRUTH IS THAT, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S SOME PEOPLE SAYING, YOU
KNOW, THAT LAW NEEDS TO BE
CHANGED.
UNTIL WE GET TO HEAR FROM A
CANDIDATE, WE SHOULDN'T ALLOW
THAT TO BE THE CASE.
>> Jesse: EARLY VOTING.
>> Jeanine: SOME ARE SAYING HE
SHOULD BE DISQUALIFIED.
>> Dana: OKAY.
SO IN PENNSYLVANIA, YOU HAVE 50
DAYS OF EARLY VOTING.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY IN THE
WORLD YOU NEED 50 DAYS.
THAT'S UP TO THE PENNSYLVANIANS
TO DECIDE.
THEY SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT THEIR
LAW.
EVERY STATE GETS TO DECIDE.
I BROUGHT IT UP YESTERDAY.
A REASONABLE REQUEST FROM THE
VOTERS, WE SHOULD HAVE ONE
DEBATE BEFORE THERE'S EARLY
VOTING.
THAT WOULD ENSURE THERE WERE
DEBATES.
>> Jesse: GOOD POINT.
>> Dana: LIKE IN ARIZONA WHERE
KATIE HOBBS WON'T DEBATE KARI
LAKE.
NOW MAYBE SHE'S GOING I GUESS
THAT WAS A GOOD DECISION EVEN
THOUGH IT HURT HER IN THE POLLS
AND SHE'S BEHIND ON KARI LAKE.
PART OF THIS WAS NOT BY
ACCIDENT.
THEY WANT TOLD BANK AS IN EARLY
VOTES ACTION THEY COULD BEFORE
PEOPLE COULD SEE WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
WHAT IS UNFORTUNATE, REMEMBER
THAT NBC REPORTER DASHA BURNS
THAT DID THE REPORT WITH
FETTERMAN.
IN THE SMALL TALK, SHE FOUND HE
HAD A HARD TIME PROCESSING
LANGUAGE.
SHE GOT RIDICULED.
TURNS OUT THE REPORTERS GOING
AFTER HER HAD DONE INTERVIEWS
WITH FETTERMAN AND THEY ARE LIKE
HE'S FINE.
GUESS WHAT?
THEY USED THE CLOSED CAPTIONING
SYSTEM.
THAT'S NOT WHAT DASHA BURNS HAD
WHEN SHE DID THE SMALL TALK.
THAT WAS HER POINT.
THEY WENT AFTER HER ANYWAY.
IT WAS WRONG.
>> Jeanine: GERALDO?
>> Geraldo: THREE THINGS TO SAY.
I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
TIME.
I LIKE DR. OZ A LOT.
HE AND HIS WIFE, LISA ARE
WONDERFUL PEOPLE, ALWAYS NICE TO
ME AND ERIKA.
HE DID ERIKA'S UNCLE KENNY'S
HEART.
THAT'S DR. OZ.
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES HAVE
SHOWN TIME AND TIME AGAIN THEY
CAN FUNCTION.
LISTEN TO THIS.
THE SENATE WAS ONCE CONSIDERED
THE WORLD'S GREATEST
DELIBERATIVE BODY.
I WONDER HOW IMPORTANT ARE
HERSCHEL WALKERS FAILINGS TO
REPUBLICANS AND FETTERMAN'S
IMPAIRMENTS TO DEMOCRATS.
26 TIMES KAMALA HARRIS HAS
BROKEN THE TIE.
IT'S ALL ABOUT LOYALTY.
TALKING ABOUT HIS COGNITIVE THIS
OR THAT FOR WHAT?
FOR SHAKING HANDS TO THE
HARRISBURG DELEGATION THAT COMES
TO VISIT HIS OFFICE IN
WASHINGTON D.C.?
>> Jesse: IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
50/50 FOREVER.
THIS IS A SIX-YEAR JOB.
>> Jeanine: THIS IS A JOB THAT
REQUIRES DISCUSSION AND
UNDERSTANDING.
>> Geraldo: DOES IT REALLY?
>> Jeanine: YEAH.
>> Geraldo: ALWAYS THE
REPUBLICANS VOTE FOR
REPUBLICANS.
>> Jesse: NO, THEY DON'T.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH THE
REPUBLICANS.
THEY DON'T ALWAYS VOTE WITH
>> Dana: THE BIGGEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT BIDEN GOES OUT
AND TALKS ABOUT